I had lost my own passion for my own
work my life looked fine and good but I
didn't want to wake up and go to work
anymore and what I discovered was based
on the biology of human decision making
this little model why how and what and I
realized I knew how I did things and I
knew what I did but I didn't know why
and so the idea of purpose has nothing
to do with business it's a deep-seated
human need our need to belong is deeply
ingrained in us and the more we feel
like we belong to our tribe and the more
that we feel that our our company and
our our work has has meaning Beyond just
the money we make in the product we sell
it actually is incredibly fulfilling and
Incredibly joyful and it just so happens
it's exceptionally good for business
organizations that have a clear sense of
purpose use that sense of purpose to
make decisions higher to that sense of
purpose build structure and sentence
around that purpose tend to outperform
tend to out innovate their competitors
over the long term almost almost always